I had a guy do this to me watch this he
goes I said what'd he do he goes get rid
of pain in fear I go I was like dude you
guys yeah so ask me just questions
that's what I do what are you do I get
rid of pain in fear oh yeah yeah how you
got pain yeah I do come you got fear
sometimes gone you work with me God nope
oh wow yeah it doesn't exist after you
work with me oh I love this so I go
really
so then we have a he gives me an
introductory class and I love a [ __ ]
train wreck and I love a con man so I go
you went oh yeah probably 15 years ago
oh I don't matter because I just wanted
to I was so yeah look him up on the
Internet I actually liked him because he
said something interesting to me he got
you I said he works with people and I
said what what about me what would you
say about me he goes uh you he says
thing inside places you have one idea of
strengths and there are different
strengths and I said whoa and he said he
said your idea of strength is you know
like like dogs if a dog fought a cat
what would happen I got a dog killer cat
he goes yeah but what if but but but
could the dog catch the cat and I was
like oh yeah it was just a different
thing that God you know you know you
just waste all your time in life you're
not a dog and cats have their own
strength it was a long conversation you
know there's different kind of strengths
which we had a good conversation about
we get to his place and he has he has a
glass of water because some water for
you and I go to read for you is not yet
don't don't read for yet that's why I'm
letting it sit in the Sun because when
the water sits in the Sun it absorbs the
sun's energy and you'll feel much much
more power this is oh no but I loved it
I went through the hypnosis hypnotize he
goes out he goes what are you afraid of
it like you know wake up with it was
great then he came out with a robe in my
hood no one dresses up which is such a
shame my best friend's a teacher and
tank Rita and her class all dressed up
yeah yeah I think it depends react yeah
must be must be the districts so
Halloween was cool and then for
Valentine's Day I was if you had a crush
on a girl love game on because it was so
hard you can't slip their little
freaking thing without candy heart in it
are you ready I'm remembering all this
stuff now that I haven't thought about
in forever remember that you do then
also in high school it sucked I wonder
if they still do sigh but they don't
they can't play dodgeball for God's
sakes cuz kids get picked on but I
remember you could send roses or flowers
to someone in class
they would knock on the door and become
like we have a rose for a Ashley and
then come in - wait yeah you know but
the girls I think it um it sucked man I
feel like it's Aaron Burr in high school
we had that and me and my best friend
for my French class we wrote like dirty
French notes to each other like this is
a joke and the ASB people didn't like
read it obviously they didn't know what
it said so they wrote it on the roses
and they ended up passing the Roses
during French class so that my French
teacher was like oh let's see who got
roses and let's read out your notes
aloud and so like my friend end up
eating the note oh do you remember
teachers man remember when you pass
notes with obviously these days kids can
text each other whatever they want take
pates whatever gift mean whatever but
when I was a kid this can be same with
you Chad did your cell phone in school I
had it to go phone yeah cusp of that
generation of me Wow we at the past note
yeah we like write notes the teachers
that would intercept those notes like
we're [ __ ] Russian spies what the
[ __ ] and then sometimes they would read
them out so oh my god the nerve I
remember but did you pass my footballs
were you like what folded up in a
football yeah or a triangle or something
pretty classy to deliver to my friend
Lea that likes pass they pass it like or
they'd write back be your kids man so
far no memory lane right now it was we
used to write and freaking notes and
then pass them around and you know it's
not for your teachers eyes or the dog
eyes we would make fun of the teacher
yes and my Spanish class we make fun of
her name it's Wessel
miss Wetzel and then we all we did was
just draw cartoons and pass it and it
won't add to the cartoon let's go about
her but just so mean but your dad yeah
and then would she get it I don't think
she ever found it yeah god it's the
bummer when they get it yeah luckily if
she found it I would have felt horrible
because it would have broken her heart
and we're just trying to have fun
you also yeah your kids you know you
know yeah you know thinking like that
jeez man so those are the things that
kids these days are missing out on like
those little things like you're putting
it together you're creating stuff and
you're passing it you don't do that not
running your fingers to your silkiest
[ __ ] hair dude hey bro
get me some of that stuff what is it I
get you a wig oh man what age do you
think hopefully by death drives me crazy
my mother who says that what a wig I'm
with your mom what do you mean you're
with my mom
it's a [ __ ] wig duty Martinez I don't
give a [ __ ] what am I gonna do walk
around with a wig nobelium Steve Meyer
people are gonna see that they did I
have a wake Brian Urlacher does better
than Brian
that's the worst he looked great bald I
don't want to talk my wife worried like
she was dressed like a llama I gotta be
honest a llama adorable
a llama [ __ ] yes she had a little tail
she had curly little head little hoodie
and curly curly little thing oh you'd
look like a llama like the up off of
Emperor's New Groove it was just like a
pink but furry suit like a flan is Rp a
pink jumpsuit and she's a pig
no cuz she was our pillow she had curly
hair she had a little tail the llama
tail a little nose on the top it was so
cute I was like you [ __ ] cute she had
praise I was like furry actually yeah I
was I he [ __ ] you forgive a man I
know you listen show you that's llamas
aren't pink no super confusing no you're
a unicorn you don't know she was a pink
la musica mute me I was dressed I got
she bought she put me I got a red outfit
on it had horns but they were kind of
like bull horns you were dead really I
don't know it was shitty little cow
horns with a shitty tail and a little
soft nose so it was a hood with a soft
nose on the [ __ ] end it sucked it was
an tiny [ __ ] wings the whole shitty wig
you could never fly Cisco
yeah she was a pink llama yeah Dora you
were a shitty Satan I was a red I'm red
to hell I was a Red Cow than your son
kind of a white supremacist yeah machine
yeah that kept falling and what was your
daughter well alright so I'm glad you
asked now do the counts do howling the
worst in America the worst you can
imagine would you side she's awesome but
I don't do anything of course cuz mmm
bad dad but I yeah I saw there I am with
my my it's a you understand what I'm
saying right it's like it's got booties
and you get into it it's jumpsuit it's
zip so who does me it could trip him
then I got my hood I put it over right
so I got tiny holes me pictures anyway I
don't know I got it I threw it away in
the middle it got too hot
my daughter was dressed as a Anne Archer
sort of she had an archery outfit on
sort of like she was dressed like a
forest Archer and a little shitty bow
like Robin yeah and I said you're a
Huntress and she goes no I'm not I go
okay she goes I shoot a bow and arrow
and that was her custom so it was yeah
it bit of a closer feels a little bit
that's what Halloween is